those who are useful angelo they
came to intervene with
travelers they were restrained like that to
come and arrest a
potentially dangerous traveler
potentially armed in fact in france
when we travel people for the
police and the institutions we are  just
potentially fed up I I I think
all the gypsies in the world I think we
're the most hated of all the
other rich age communities for
real I think for real and I
don't know why
to believe than to see  Stealing hens at
the time it's because we call you
hen thieves that it's finally
I'm not that there must have been only one
of the hens we took it that shocked them
this time I  know well I do
n't understand what we could have done at jean prat
also feared
I arrived in Corsica since when this
very small then I came to the camp
since each my husband I have been
married for 13 years and
but this is a done  not long and
I am  very happy with what I like
is being together
[Music]
magnify the title
camille youth selections
[Music]
saint denis
match de  beach and sikasso idea was
given to saint denis
[Music]
and there are the sleeves and going there is naked
and to the sintis and the gypsies so we
can see we can already see that we have a
problem with the roms which are
came from eastern countries where people
people did not understand that in fact the
roma they have been in france for
years and to roma in france
for hundreds of years
tlj he had exposed his it is  for the summer
and there I have gifts from my daughter who
married aviles samarie last week
there and all the cases of others
took them like that when I speak and
and I can join my family I'm
right they  always have because when
the word rom comes out in the same in the
dense and dental mouth he immediately thinks
of them to the people of
eastern countries knew that the roma in france they
can no longer even say I am roma
because if they say I am roma immediately
they will say it's a caravan the bad
first and where the rule all  tags
on it that make a lot of mess and or
when in reality it's not that at all
today in France we have roms who
are lawyers we have roms that they
have situations of these world of gypsies
stadium
[  Music]
[Music]
[Music
] French equals 36
[Music]
his name in romania wherever you want and
then business and they're not French they
came here they're settled here
they're everywhere on the lookout for  okay
but we and the roma from france because
in france too the roma in france there
are also roma it sets us apart
from france so we are going to go where we don't have
b it's at home  also but we are
not considered as French
so for some it is true here
we checked the family fact it is the
family here maxi  me courby so
today me I'm having you show
how you judge you see see that it
's caravans that it's caravans
today that that you 35000
euros caravans like that at 35000 euros is
what you think that today  'today we
can pay taxes while we
refuse to land somewhere it's
me just like that here it's a land
that the town hall had put on a
temporary basis
we weren't supposed to stay long we
stayed more than 40 years  it is a text
whose objective is to bring
together people who have
different lifestyles the itinerant mode
for travelers and for
most of our country has a
sedentary mode and sometimes
cohabitation is difficult it  it must be
regulated and this is therefore the objective of this
text and in particular of the
fixed fine which is a fine which will be
applied only to
persons who do not respect the law and
who illegally or
unlawfully occupy public land  and
private people parading everywhere
today want to
put us 1500 euros fine per day for
a chalet or sailboats to
cook it's 1500 euros fine per
day for a caravan it's 500  euros
fine per day count the caravans
which have a fine of 500 euros per day and
I am you think that we can live
on the champs elysées because we are
tearing up the land on the edition of
on others
we are on the ground  people we put
ourselves all the same we you because we have
no choice but I don't want to say that and
it is precisely because a good number
finally not lay a certain number of
communities very often
minorities these  some communities
that create problems that will
settle in land that is
not intended for this purpose in
agricultural areas in
commercial areas in industrial areas creating
problems of breach
of public order problems of  hygiene or even
physical attacks  verbal s in our
department two mayors were physically assaulted
1 for some it was a
fairly significant assault
simon ledieu and
[Music]
there I go out that for bad cases is
not the workplace with the girls
that's visible from  time that I had a
lot of experience
with girls like a prince in the
days
[Music]
when life is beautiful from the ubo
the mayors there were in our house there
are mothers yes good nerves  big
names who are going to go to housing estates and
social housing estates either they are going to go there you
from me never of the year easy good when
they want to be elected the mayor of france
to go on pleasure is to
introduce myself I myself  present at the elections
it happens to me to happen in all the
French districts but you never
passed him in gypsy years
our politicians understand it's weird
but it's races that are aggressive
between we couldn't we couldn't
on the other hand but take the tro  is there
she remained three patients and
suddenly we couldn't find the bottom because
because it's a race cd shaves that they
were selected to be that it is
aggressive between them that means that if
we put the  three in the field they
would fight detroit gypsies so
almost cost me dearly in france me me
it's the most beautiful country in the world for
me I say thoroughly but I'll tell
you that you know it's there in fact the le  the
problem is that we call ethnicity
we like and we are a country where we accept
all communities we had the impression that we
travelers who are a community born
in the country that means that d  'other
municipalities and she's been there for
generations
with her pass and yet a price
Thursday in basel to you paribas that I'll
tell you I think we can't wait and
Thursday in doha time to consider them
as strangers when was born  in france
what i think it's rather simple
role and that's what i said ah yeah
it's  what i found to say is
that we are foreigners from france but
we are there
in parliament so she went to
the assembly that she was deeply
watered down and i regret it because there
is  a certain number of measures
worried that they were measures to
precisely allow this better living
together which have disappeared but a law
cannot be discriminatory if it
was discriminatory
the constitutional council then it
of course repealed flag the blue it
represents the  water and lucile levre
represent the forests and the greenery
where the caravan is and red
is the meaning of the years is that they have
slipped on the road
[Music]
any action leads to a reaction is
a reaction of my  shower it hurts a lot
[Music]
[Applause]
my name is aurélie garant I am the
sister of angelo garant my brother was
killed on March 30, 2007 at my
parents' home he was shot five times in
the
torso makes the story  e d'angelo is
the story of a man who took you to prison
and september 2016 he didn't want to
grant leave for a single
day and he didn't come back and for
six months angelo arrived right to left
where  he wanted
on March 30, 2017 he is better to eat at
my parents' house
and there around 1 p.m. it is a team from the
gign who arrives when I have one
of the brands
my brother this case just in a small
dead-end shed
his reach  as gign arrives he puts
my whole family on the ground handcuffed behind his back
machine gun under the tent
they searched the premises but caravan
the building they did not search the
shed
but toulon what my family was
closed the farm alas he was ready to
to leave when there was a small noise
in the shed is there these five men from the
gign who are rushed and my parents
were five meters away
they all saw nothing
silenced shots
it is to join the army if one
beat my brother with his cold we
learned later from sal  ima the sprain
heart liver and lung
me i don't know cause i
never seen a girl who goes to school
consent
i don't wanna be the
first east by the dal and like  that with the
belly
at school after eric daman second not
give him a good month but for you
[Music]
rosa which goes from this not positive but
not long ago in france you have
circulation books where  every 3
months 6 months we had to knock them off
the other places of reception, that is to say
that m me, I live there in montpellier that
I am in paris for six months with
magali we would have to come down from paris
to get a stamp there  where I'm
happy to follow us the class
do you realize
we have to give everything cc it's me I
would say it's practices that are
nazis I mean it's practice
of asia for me you  understand to
control the population
what does it mean finally the commissioner of police
or the gendarmerie and every 3 months
fall  need us to sign so there I have a
few months I have friends and if
years of signatures in my little
notebook my identical wife
we kept that for years years
where we were going to clock in as if we
were  wanted by the police
every three months we had to win so
it was complicated had to go
it was just in case if we had
done something they didn't know
where to find us so we got fed up and
then  one day well
[Music]
problem he smiles look because they
are curious to see what is happening
not like we read at mans
we do that no no there is nothing after
he passed
[  Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
m
[Music]
it's now
no times
[Music]
listen to the fangs so that's the law
because
it was it was finished on  November 8,
2018 on the way his voice his designers
of haute savoie who originally had
put cat you want  that he had done and
this law against roma and
hungaria passed as I explained to you
dayraut use the flag to say
that they are travellers, so I
don't know travellers, they are
people who come  immigrants in france
quite simply they are not traveling people
but they are not in the
caravans they are not their trip
all year round like us it is not the
provision that will infringe they are the ones
who infringe the law because I
repeat this fixed fine will only
apply to those towards
those who have broken the law who
occupy land that is not
provided for this purpose who will not
go on the land set up
as part of the departmental scheme
so this set to precisely
enforce the law to people who do
n't respect it lapointe times it's the
most beautiful country in the world
we have a social system which we'll say if
we don't want to take it good
then as we won't  quote but he
there are many countries that don't have our
social system
children spoiled children,
that is to say that it's true that if we
're sick we get treatment
if we don't have enough to finish the most day
we give but  i see france a
little common like a pedophile dad
that means you buy a nice
car but i touch you story you
feel the heat experienced the fate of
prison